mit ach und krach ist die linke im
bundestag gelandet und bei
landtagswahlen ist hier immer öfter
erfolglos ausgerechnet in zeiten in
denen ihre kernthemen eigentlich
besonders erfolgreich seien müssten
kämpft die linke muss politische
überleben um den kurs ihrer partei und
mit einem hauseigenen sexismus skandal
warum ist die linke in deutschland so
sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt das
frage ich den mann der das ändern will
den neu gewählten co parteivorsitzende
martin schirdewahn heute hier in jena
herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo herr schütte war
natürlich willkommen beim zdf
sommerinterview rom geschehen diesmal
hier in thüringen auf dem kulturgut
ulrichs halten das ist ganz in der nähe
von jena einer ihrer politischen
wirkungsstätten ich muss sagen es war
gar nicht so einfach festzustellen wo
wir sie am besten treffen denn sie haben
nicht nur in jena ein wahlkreisbüro sie
unterhalten auch 1 in hannover sie
arbeiten in straßburg und in brüssel und
sie leben in berlin und jetzt kommt noch
der parteivorsitz dazu da fragt man sich
so ein bisschen machen sie das dann im
nebenjob nein natürlich nicht ich
konzentriere mich mit ganzer kraft auf
den parteivorsitz und werde trotzdem das
mandat in brüssel behalten weil das eine
gute voraussetzung ist auch für die
partei gestärkt in die vor uns liegen
europameister im jahr 2024 zu ziehen und
hier in thüringen sind sie
wahrscheinlich ganz gerne weil hier die
linke welt noch in ordnung ist hier
stellen sie sogar noch den
ministerpräsidenten allerdings
entspricht das nicht ganz der realität
der partei eben rest deutschlands da
sind sie zuletzt von einer wahlschlappe
in die nächste gegangen gregor gysi hat
das jetzt gerade auf dem parteitag eine
existenzielle krise genannt hat er recht
damit ja erstmal freue ich mich total
dass wir uns diesen thüringen treffen wo
bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident ist
natürlich ist diese landesregierung für
uns als partei von enormer bedeutung
weil wir hier auch konkret unter beweis
stellen was für gute politik wir machen
und wieder beweisen dass täglich in dem
er verbesserungen für die thüringerinnen
und thüringer vornehmen aber die
ausnahme das ist wichtig ausnahme wir
sind an vier landesregierung beteiligt
wir sind stark in den kommunen wir sind
dann viele landesregierung beteiligt wir
haben eine starke und gut
funktionierende bundestagsfraktionen wir
sind stark auf in europa aufgestellt von
daher die linke ist da und wir werden
auch aus dieser krise die zum teil
hausgemacht ist uns wieder
herausarbeiten stelle fest das wort
existenzkrise wollen sie hier noch nicht
benutzen wir schauen gleich mal wie
schwierig ist denn insgesamt will ihre
partei im moment ist das machen wir
vorne
[Musik]
eriwan in zeiten wie diesen könnte ihre
partei eigentlich sehr gefragt sein weil
die themen armut und inflation gerade
sehr stark sind da verstehen sie sich
selbst als anwalt der besonders
betroffenen menschen aber ihre
umfragewerte momentan sind seit einiger
zeit besonders schlecht sie haben
persönliche erfahrungen mit schlechten
wahlergebnissen sie sind 2017 ins
europäische parlament nur als nachrücker
gekommen sie haben 2009 10 als
spitzenkandidat dann das wahlergebnis
der linken nochmal verschlechtert jetzt
sagen sie seit dem parteitag wir haben
verstanden alles wird besser ich frag
mich warum sollen denn die probleme mit
einem parteitag einfach so verschwinden
nein die probleme der sich die partei
befindet verschwinden natürlich nicht
mit einem parteitag aber wir haben
weichen gestellt wir haben inhaltlich
weichen gestellt wir haben personelle
weichen gestellt und die stimmung auf
dem parteitag war tatsächlich sehr gut
sehr kämpferisch weil genau die
situation so ist wie sie sie geschildert
haben wir stehen vor einer
existenziellen krise aber nicht als
linke sondern in dieser gesellschaft die
armut beträgt 16,6 prozent fast 14
millionen deutsche leben in armut sind
von armut betroffen und zugleich blicken
in einer situation entgegen wo die
energiepreise ungebremst ansteigen wo
die nahrungsmittelpreise ungebremst
ansteigen und die leute wirklich angst
haben davor über den monat zu kommen und
da braucht es eine starke linke
opposition und die sind wir und wir sind
bereit diese rolle auszufüllen um stark
zu werden haben sie selber in den
letzten wochen oft diskutiert dass da
ein bisschen was passieren muss in der
partei ihre ambitionen sind noch relativ
frisch sie sind erst vor zwei wochen zum
parteivorsitzenden gewählt worden und
welches schwere erbe sie da antreten das
wollen wir jetzt einmal anschauen daniel
ponce in mein kollege hat das sind 60
sekunden zusammengefasst die stimmung
beim parteitag gereizt da wir uns in
einer existenziellen krise befinden das
müssen wir alle begreifen beim begreifen
hilft ein blick auf die wahlergebnisse
im bund im saarland in
schleswig-holstein uns in nrw
die ursachen dafür vielfältig oft
hausgemacht sie mit skandal bei dessen
erster langsam offen wird das ist ein
netz ist als das bundes weiteres stadt
gemeinsame antworten etwa auf wachsende
armut permanente selbst beschädigungen
im dickicht unterschiedlichster
machtzirkel sticht ein konflikt immer
wieder hervor sahra wagenknecht gegen
das wechselnde führungspersonal der
antrag sie auszuschließen abgelehnt auch
weil sich die partei im wahlkampf selbst
mit ihr schmückte und nun sarah
wagenknecht ist eins von 60.000
parteimitgliedern und unsere partner
lebt davon dass sich 60.000
parteimitglieder aktiv um die politische
arbeit einbringen beide hätten
wahlniederlagen zu verantworten
entgegnete sie zum neuen duo fazit never
change a winning team ja herr schrade
waren never change you singt ihm also
bloß nicht das verliererteam austauschen
das zielt auf sie und das sagt die
prominenteste politikerin ihrer partei
wie passt das zu ihrer behauptung vom
parteitag dass jetzt alle an einem
strang ziehen na ja das ist natürlich
auch eine stilfrage wie man mit
demokratischen entscheidungen eines
parteitages umgeht das muss jede und
jeder für sich entscheiden aber janine
wissler meine co vorsitz und ich freue
mich sehr auf die zusammenarbeit und
bedanke mich im übrigen auch bei dem
parteitag für das starke vertrauen dass
sowohl berlin als auch ich erfahren
haben hat mehrmals als spitzenkandidat
in die linke in hessen in den landtag
geführt ich habe als partner
fraktionsvorsitzender im europäischen
parlament bewiesen wie man erfolgreich
linke politik gestaltet wir sind hier in
thüringen in meinem landesverband gibt
es einen linken ministerpräsidenten ihn
und ich und auch die partei wir sind uns
schon bewusst erfolge organisiert sahra
wagenknecht schafft allerdings etwas was
viele in ihrer partei nicht schaffen sie
mobilisiert mit starken themen können
sie sich dann einen bruch mit ihr
überhaupt leisten es geht da nicht um
bruch es geht um eine gute
zusammenarbeit derjenigen die
verantwortung in der partei tragen und
wir als
parteivorsitzender sind gewillt sowohl
mit der fraktion intensiv und gut
zusammenzuarbeiten wir haben das in den
letzten zwei wochen auch schon getan wir
stehen in regelmäßigem austausch und es
geht genau darum gemeinsam politik zu
entwickeln und die gemeinsamen
positionen dann auch geschlossen nach
außen zu vertreten zum beispiel nicht
aber nicht dazu wer zum beispiel wenn es
um die gestiegenen energiepreise geht
und wie reine energiepreis deckel ordern
oder wenn es darum geht den anstieg der
nahrungsmittelpreise zu bremsen dann
vertreten wir alle die gleichen
positionen und alle führenden
politikerinnen und politiker unserer
partei äußern sich entsprechend auch und
das ist auch notwendig weil eine
ampelkoalition eine linke opposition
braucht eine starke opposition der
geschlossen agiert sie haben gerade eben
gesagt mit den verantwortlichen in der
fraktion arbeiten sie auch gut zusammen
da gibt es starke unterstützung für
sahra wagenknecht sie müssten sie sind
nur eine fraktion mit einer mit einer
hauchdünnen mehrheit sozusagen wenn nur
drei leute ausreden bei ihnen aus der
faktoren dann ist der fraktionsstatus
weg das könnten wagenknecht unterstützer
seien die haben sie jetzt gerade nicht
mit eingeschlossen in ihrer erklärung
wir konzentrieren uns auf gemeinsame
politik entwicklungen das betrifft auch
die zusammenarbeit mit der fraktion und
sarah war geschlecht ist mitglied der
fraktion das heißt wir konzentrieren uns
auf gemeinsame politik entwicklung mit
der fraktion mit den landesverbänden mit
unseren regierungs verbänden um
tatsächlich wieder erkennbarer in der
öffentlichkeit in erscheinung zu treten
unser politisches profil zu schärfen und
das brauchen die leute aber man muss
sich die situation ansehen die gaspreise
steigen durch die decke die leute
kriegen rechnungen ins haus ich habe
gehört von einer frau gestern erst deren
rechnungen 115 prozent angestiegen ist
die wissen einfach nicht mehr wie sie
diese rechnung bezahlen sondern da
braucht es uns die der regierung auf die
füße treten weil die regierungspolitik
nicht dazu führt dass die soziale
situation der menschen gerade verbessern
wird angesichts der kaufkraft eine die
regierung hätte ich auch einige
kritische fragen wir sind jetzt aber bei
ihrer partei und ich möchte noch einmal
bei sarah wagenknecht bleiben weil sie
haben jetzt gesagt man bindet sie mit 1
allerdings in übernehmen sie da ja einen
konflikt der seit jahren schwelt und der
auch beim schon in einem
ausschlussverfahren gipfelte das nicht
geklappt hat ich würde gern mal beim aus
der entscheidung der
landesschiedskommission
nordrhein-westfalen zitieren die gesagt
hat nein wir schließen diese frau nicht
aus weil die partei in wahlkampfzeiten
sich ihrer bekanntheit und ihre
öffentlichen wirksamkeit bedient und
eine weitere begründung war weil sie als
partei es versäumt haben die politische
entscheidung über strittige themen
herbeizuführen die sahra wagenknecht
immer wieder nach vorne geschoben hat
wenn ich ihnen jetzt so zuhöre dann habe
ich auch den eindruck sie schieben die
diskussionen und frau wagenknecht
beiseite und stellen sie nicht
argumentativ
ich entwickelte politik wir entwickeln
politikern wir vertreten diese position
geschlossene parteitag hat klare
entscheidung gefällt was zum beispiel
die frage der verbindung von sozialer
frage und ökologischer frage betrifft
wir wollen die energiewende fördern wir
fordern 100 milliarden sofortprogramm
für die energiewende um auch aus der
abhängigkeit der fossilen energieträger
zum beispiel aus russland zu kommen das
den positionen die von der fraktion und
die mitglieder der fraktion genauso
bezahlt werden wie von der partei und
auch den landesverbänden das sind die
dinge die wir nach vorne sticht sie
richtig sie erwarten von frau
wagenknecht jetzt volle rückendeckung
für an ihre positionen ich erwarte dass
die führenden politikerinnen und
politiker meiner partei die position die
wir miteinander demokratisch verhandeln
und bestimmen auch nach außen hin
vertreten ja sie haben sich gerade eben
bedankt dafür dass sie mit ihrer co
vorsitzenden janine wissler
zusammenarbeiten dürfen allerdings sind
sie jetzt in einer relativ schwierigen
phase sie müssen einen neustart hin
bekommen und zu den problemen in ihrer
partei gehört beim hausinterner skandal
und die diskussion über strukturellen
sexismus und sexuelle gewalt und
übergriffe war ein großes thema bei
ihnen auf dem parteitag da haben sie
eigentlich eine angezählte
co-vorsitzende an ihrer seite war
kritiker sagen die rolle von janine
wissler bei der aufklärung eines falles
sexuellen übergriffes ist noch nicht
ausreichend geklärt es gab eine
vorsitzende die zurückgetreten ist aus
prinzip in diesem zusammenhang das war
vorher nicht weil so die andere stand in
whistler hat das nicht getan ist da die
falsche vorsitzende zurückgetreten
daneben genießt das vertrauen der partei
der parteitag hat sie mit einem stark
und einem klaren ergebnis in die rolle
als co vorsitzender jetzt meine co
vorsitzende gewählt und wir arbeiten
sehr gut und vertrauensvoll zusammen und
unser gemeinsames interesse ist dass wir
den sexismus skandal und auch die
überfälle dies dort gab tatsächlich
aufklären und das ist auch wichtig an
dieser stelle nicht mit dem
jugendverband insbesondere sehr dankbar
dass wir diese intensive emotionale
anstrengende und auch kleine debatte auf
dem parteitag geführt haben weil wir
unserem anspruch als feministische
partei in der vergangenheit nicht in
allen fällen gerecht werden reicht da
aufklären
aufklären und entsprechende strukturen
schaffen um solche fälle in zukunft zu
verhindern dafür gehen wir jetzt
miteinander als partei die
entsprechenden schritte und es braucht
vor allem eine kuh wo die leute die in
unserer partei politik machen wollen die
mit unserer polizei politik machen
wollen sich sicher fühlen also die
partei als ein sicherer ort für alle es
ist keine erklärung dass in der
gesellschaft passe ich habe strukturen
existieren dass dort macht hierarchien
existieren dafür ist in unserer partei
kein platz zukünftig und dafür werden
wir sorgen beschreiben sie was nicht
ausreicht aber wenn sie das alles
strukturell aufgestellt haben wie wollen
sie denn sicherstellen dass diejenigen
die auch früher als sie da vergehen
begangen haben schon wussten dass sie
grenzen überschreiten dann in zukunft
diese grenzen nicht mehr überschreiten
indem es eine kultur gibt die das
verhindert indem es strukturen gibt an
die sich betroffene wenden können indem
es eine expertin und pool gibt wir haben
jetzt eine expertenkommission berufen
die die leute so
sozialpsychologisch als rechtlich
beraten und wir schaffen alle
voraussetzungen mit solchen fällen und
solchen gelegenheiten kein raum mehr
gebetet und den lieben konsequenz auch
ausschluss für täter das ist eine
juristische entscheidung das obliegt mir
hier an dieser stelle nicht diese
entscheidungen zu fällen dafür schaffen
wir aber ein expertenpool der
betroffenen zur seite stehen wenn sie
das dann begrüßen konsequentes
durchgreifen wenn es zu fällen kommt wo
es eine juristische konsequenz braucht
dann würde ich das begrüßen
sie haben noch andere altlasten mit
denen sie sich herumschlagen unter
anderem in der außenpolitik da haben sie
gerade heftige diskussionen geführt als
es um die frage ging wie geht man mit
russlands angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
zu auch da war der parteitag sehr bewegt
es gab einen sehr bewegenden moment nach
einer langen debatte in der es viele
redebeiträge gab wo die ukraine und
russland fast gleich gesetzt worden ging
eine junge frau mit großem entsetzen ans
mikrofon die frau hat eine ukrainische
familie und wir hören uns mal kurz an
was sie gesagt hat hier wurde gesagt
dass es
genauso wie realistisch ist sich zu
verteidigen gegen einen brutalen
angriffs krieg bei dem menschen getötet
gefoltert werden genauso unrealistisch
sei wie den krieg zu beginnen und die
leute zu morden wie kann das sein wie
kann kein aufschrei passieren er schade
waren sie haben dann einen
parteitagsbeschluss mit durchgesetzte
den angriffskrieg ganz klar verurteilt
aber fakt ist auch nennenswerte teile
ihrer partei relativieren die
verantwortung russland das schaffen sie
doch nicht einfach mit einem beschluss
aus der welt naja die diskussion das ein
bisschen anders verlaufen meiner
wahrnehmung es gab verschiedene anträge
die behandelt worden die auch sehr
intensiv aber durchaus solidarisch
miteinander diskutiert worden sind und
den beiden entscheidenden anträgen ist
deutlich geworden dass wir als linke den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine aufs schärfste
und ohne wenn und aber verurteilen das
gilt auch für unsere solidarität mit der
ukraine das heißt die junge frau sofia
verlängere hat nicht recht mit ihrer
wahrnehmung ich habe mit ihr gesprochen
auf dem parteitag wir haben uns
miteinander verständigt und ich bin ja
auch sehr dankbar dass sie diesen sehr
starken und auch emotional starken
beitrag gehalten hat war das eine
position ist sie auch in unserer partei
platz haben muss dass wir darüber
nachdenken welche mittel die richtigen
sind zur unterstützung der ukraine und
wir unterstützen die ukraine politisch
indem wir zum beispiel auch den beitritt
stand kandidatenstatus für die ukraine
zur eu unterstützen wir unterstützen
jede diplomatische offensive die darauf
abzielt diesen elenden krieg endlich zu
beenden der unerträglich ist und auch
die kriegsverbrechen begangen werden
sind unerträglich und kaum aushalten wir
unterstützen die ukraine ökonomische
indem wir sanktionen befürworten wir
unterstützen die ukraine finanziell in
dem wir jetzt einzige partei in
deutschland einen schuldenschnitt für
die ukraine fordern damit die ukraine
auch in kriegszeiten löhne und renten
zahlen kann und wir unterstützen die
ukraine humanitär ich selbst habe eine
geflüchteten familie bei mir aufgenommen
von sechs menschen also wir unterstützen
wo wir können das ist eine sehr lange
liste wo sie nicht unterstützen wollen
das sind waffenlieferungen da sind sie
ganz klar das wollen sie auf gar keinen
fall ich hab mal nachgeschaut sie hatten
in der in einem interview der
süddeutschen zeitung gesagt wir erklären
uns solidarisch mit der mit den
notleidenden
entschuldigung meter not leiden im
ukrainischen zivilbevölkerung aber
zugleich haben sie persönlich im
europäischen parlament gegen die
beitrittsperspektive in die eu für die
ukraine gestimmt da haben sie gesagt
nein da bin ich dagegen was meinen sie
wie solidarisch finden das denn die
menschen in der ukraine
ich habe gegen eine resolution gestützt
und da ich mich sehr sehr klar
ausgesprochen habe dafür dass diese
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg
verurteilt wird dagegen nicht gestimmt
habe ist ein genereller kurswechsel
europäischen außen- und
sicherheitspolitik in richtung
militarisierung und aufrüstung dort
vollzieht sich ein ähnlicher prozess wie
zum beispiel in deutschland wo die
regierung ich finde in einem ad hoc
verfahren fast im affekt 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
rausgehauen hat wir brauchen einen 100
milliarden sondervermögen für die
energiewende wir brauchen sozialen
schutz der menschen vor armut derzeit
aber kein 100 jahren sondervermögen und
das habe ich entsprechend auch für die
für die bundesliga das habe ich
entsprechend aber auch auf europäische
perspektive so vertreten und dazu steht
meine partei und sie sagen sie sind
gegen militarisierung und haben sich
deswegen dagegen ausgesprochen sie
hätten sich auch enthalten können dass
das noch mal als kleine gedanken daneben
das ist ja das ist hier radikal
pazifismus den sie auch mit ihrer partei
vertreten auch programmatisch vertreten
ich muss an dieser stelle einmal eine
persönliche frage an sie stellen denn
sie haben familiäre kriegserfahrung ihr
großvater war unter den
nationalsozialisten verfolgt er ist von
amerikanischen panzertruppen aus einem
todesmarsch befreit worden schwingt denn
da bei ihnen wenn sie darüber nachdenken
ob eine ukraine nicht doch waffen
unterstützung geben sollte diese
erfahrung nicht mit doch die schwingt
bei mir natürlich würde natürlich stelle
ich mir fragen welche mittel jetzt die
richtigen sind zur unterstützung der
ukraine und ich habe genannt was meine
partei alles unterstützen was wir alles
machen und von meinem großvater mit dem
ich noch sehr intensiven kontakt hatte
als er noch lebte mit dem ich teile auch
meines lebens verbracht habe also jahre
meines lebens habe ich intensive
diskussionen geführt ich habe von ihm
vor allem einen entschlossenen
antifaschismus gelernt und ich habe von
ihm aber auch gelernt dass es ein land
hand in hand geht antifaschismus und nie
wieder krieg zu fordern an dieser stelle
dass man auch sein seine lehre die er da
gezogen hat und für uns hier sind ich
bin gar kein radikaler pazifist an der
stelle aber ich sehe sowie 40 prozent
der deutschen bevölkerung die gefahr
einer massiven eskalation dieses krieges
leben immer weitere waffen geliefert
werden und ich halte es für eine
unverantwortliche position der
bundesregierung ausschließlich auf
militär militärische lösungen zu
fokussieren einen einen krieg ein kriegs
gewinn einzufordern grundsätzlich muss
man dazu sagen ist es ja nicht das muss
man der bundesregierung auch zugestehen
es gibt auch diplomatische bemühungen
sanktionen also das was ich auch fordern
aber vor allem vonseiten entschuldigen
entschuldigen sie dass ich sie
unterbricht aber vor allem von seiten
der vereinten nationen oder zum beispiel
der italienischen regierung oder das
vatikan aber nicht von der
bundesregierung haben eine besserung
millionen und von der bundesregierung
dass das regieren wir eine thematische
auf eine serie bislang ausgegangen da
ist auf jeden fall eine klare grenze
ihrer solidarität die ziehen sie ganz
klar es gibt auch andere grenzen der
solidarität in ihrer partei klaus ernst
hat jetzt zum beispiel gerade gesagt
also bevor das gas in deutschland so
teuer wird fangen wir doch lieber wieder
den handel mit russland an und öffnen
zumindest vorübergehend nord stream 2
was sagen sie dazu
klaus ernst ist der vorsitzende des
energie und klima ausschuss des
bundestages soll ich finde richtig und
er muss das auch tun die frage nach
energiesicherheit zu stellen weil wir
uns offensichtlich auf eine energie
versorgungskrise hin bewegen könnten die
möglichkeit besteht die antwort nord
stream zwei zu eröffnen halte ich für
falsch die hatte im übrigen auch nicht
mehr wiederholt wir haben das intern
auch besprochen allein deshalb weil es
keine frage der infrastruktur ist
sondern und es darum geht dass russland
die verträge einhält und das gas weiter
liefert an dieser stelle letztendlich
geht es aber darum den weg aus der
abhängigkeit fossile energieträger aus
russland also öl und gas zu finden und
da hat er ihnen schon nochmal
widersprochen weil er gesagt hat man
kann das für ein bis zwei wochen wo ich
machen das widerspricht auch nicht ihrem
gemeinsamen parteibeschluss also das
macht ihnen nichts aus los hat da so aus
der reihe tanzt er hat wie gesagt sich
korrigiert und auch in der
öffentlichkeit an dieser stelle oder er
muss die frage nach energiesicherheit
aufwerfen als vorsitzender dieses
ausschusses das wird er in der
gesellschaft breit diskutiert welche
folgen hätte zum beispiel an einen öl im
waage für die region in schwedt und die
bundesregierung schuld noch immer einen
garantie plan für die dort beschäftigten
und ich finde das nicht akzeptabel muss
man das öl embargo in dem sinne zum
jahresende dazu hat sich die
bundesregierung verpflichtet umzusetzen
umsetzen aber gleichzeitig kann man noch
darüber nachdenken ob es nicht eine
ausnahmeregelung zumindest für die
betroffene in der region schwert gibt um
die arbeitsplätze zu sichern das braucht
einen garantie plan für die region des
brauchs jobgarantien für die leute die
unmittelbar davon betroffen sind das ist
die pflicht der bundesregierung dafür zu
sorgen dass die negativen folgen für die
deutsche gesellschaft verhindert wäre
ich das ist eine absolut legitime
diskussion die wir miteinander führen
müssen dafür wollen sie sich tag machen
und da haben sie eine abweichende stimme
damit klaus ernst jetzt schon mal wieder
zurück in die reihe geholt aber ihnen
steht noch einiges an reformarbeit bevor
das haben sie auch in den letzten wochen
schon angekündigt an dieser stelle danke
ich ihnen aber erstmal für das gespräch
herzlichen dank
das war unser sommerinterview mit dem co
vorsitzenden der linken in der kommenden
woche trifft mein kollege theo koll die
ko vorsitzende der spd saskia esken
ihnen herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und
einen schönen abend
[Musik]